whatever your expectations are like
forget you look closer at anything it's
it's gonna it's gonna be more vibrant
more beautiful you have to shift your
perspective you have to come at it from
different angles and you have to combine
those angles to get a full picture of
what it is you're dealing with five
years ago I bought a microscope online
it was probably really late at night I
specifically bought a microscope with a
camera because I just wanted to look at
stuff started looking at food it's
ubiquitous it's it's everyday stuff it's
mundane you know everyone knows an apple
I say an apple you know an apple but
you've never seen an Apple like this
I've learned that what I was doing was
this thing called microscopy it was a
science but also had an art practice
that was based on what's called bio art
I'm looking to make images that are so
magical but also true putting it in a
microscope it's just a reframe on
something you take for granted oh man I
cannot wait to see this so this is honey
the fact that we get to see a bubble
here perfectly still is crazy we know
it's a perfect sphere because if any
point was more weighted or less it would
tip and it would pop and it would break
so this is at 6 times let's go to 10
like
all this stuff in the background that
looks blurry as you roll through the
focus you get the different points that
come out when we stack that it'll create
these little stars and it's gonna look
like space like Celeste you and you
can't see it now but you will once you
put everything together I want the final
thing to give you the same feeling it
gives me when I see it for the first
time like this is the edge of onion skin
look at that there's so much texture
there's just there's an entire worlds in
this stuff everything's from this point
on it's untitled
because if I tell you what it is you
then go in thinking you know what's up
and you stop staying up and you actually
close off so if I don't tell you what it
is you get to imagine and if I can keep
you in wonder for a minute I might open
you up a tiny bit it's not about what I
think it's about what you think and
that's where real connection actually
happens not just between associations
and ideas but between people so if
you're looking for common ground start
with food because everybody eats and it
all comes from the same place
[Music]